[Music]  at 26 i took an oath  you know the one  i've been asked if what i did was worth  25 years  now i'm gonna see if it was  white and fresh i want you to go to  tulsa  are you serious  you need a cat so uh where two boss  you could earn like crazy  do whatever you want  i need to see your books are you from  the government i just knocked your guard  out and you think i'm a cpa  am i being charged with almost getting  shot because i don't think that's a  crime even in oklahoma  what's an ex mafia capo in tulsa  not figure that out you'll be the second  one you know  and brexit amigo you're precisely where  you're supposed to be  if you work for me we'll be making money  hand over fists  nightclubs discos a disco you're a  sarcastic little perk aren't you  give me a couple  years i'm gonna own this city  if anybody asks you what i do for a  living tell them i'm an industrialist  what does that even mean  my point exactly  [Music]  [Music]  you